the property reached a tion in destination and
design in which one to leave in and zambi
em off at the world wide glide neymar r 100
joy
those who took ana jorge go and
train hard that you go in search of your
dream that doesn't even matter to  barrier
that you are in front of
you trying to get in your way I
think this is part of life you
insist that you don't give up what you go in
search of your way of being your biggest
dream of being if you are a football player
or in another sport that is not  there is I think
it's the most important thing even in the love funda cattery it's
enough to face right
messi and cristiano ronaldo I played
start in what for me is one of the
greatest football is my football idol and with
him I learned every
day, every day  i watched training watching him
play playing us power so this
was strengthening me it was increasing
my ability on the field that i
learned a lot from him
while cristiano ronaldo is not a
monster it's facing him is an honor a
pleasure and  but we have to
prepare more because he is one of the greatest
in football so you get smarter
more connected but at the same time you
learn too so the 12 great
guys that who I see is not like
them because I want to learn I want to
I want to win more and I want to seek more titles to
score more goals so I'm
learning every day with him also on the subway and
chase ordins I imagined a lot in
my life I was always a guy a
dreamer and when I went to the top right
and thank God I  not only did I conquer, I
'm with her and ends up conquering other
things more
so I'm a very accomplished guy
today he's very happy with myself
hey lost I think this is the link that
transformed life right
in pursuit of my dreams being happy is
trying to help  somehow not only
my family my friends but like the
world so much a day the cashier
I didn't stop but I didn't want to see lives in
front of football right because I turn off
a little bit of everything mourning sadness but
I think  that was exaggerated like that but that's
not what I said I'm already used
to all this
I'm quite big and I already know how to deal very
well with criticism very well with
pressure it's for everyone who plays
football of course there are two weights
while  my name I know that and the
responsibility that I have but it is
not only in the national team it is like in the clubs
that I played in, what they play has always been
very big
since I was 17 years old 18 when I went to
the national team, right I already knew when I was in
charge  I wish I had prepared myself for that,
right, and I know very well that when the
results don't come, the criticism doesn't come, father
camp, the content is saved at messi's level at the
level and once you put people as
idols, it's hard to go the way the
people of  island of mallorca team said to
play in transform and manias i i i
received guinea set i want to be
always improving the morning got better
and almost had
aibeso my best here the same as what is
most important is hatmo in porto
came in suddenly  you youtube young dani
bolina ex right there useful is the one who signs
like this doesn't do it by where it's in the face
who wanted to steal fire in our idea
is to spread the wanted always to be
happy there rolls in how to follow if it would
lead to conclude like this if it is  a bankruptcy
and it doesn't even read if it was triggered a little
but it lacked winning like barcelona then
playing football for me is that the will
that has been ignoring the ers in good faith has
a stagnation in a joke with the
children about it right my
dribbling football  my football is to face the
opponent i can't make mistakes love can be
close excuse me i want to
score a goal i can't i have to
try to dribble him i have to try
to make him not let go
he will be missed there and many  sometimes I
'm faster than what players
eat and lighter and it ends up being missed
is the referee is there for that, right and if you think
I want to be fouled be careful
not because it hurts it hurts it's after the
games I'm making gel  the 45 hours is
complicated
but those who don't understand said those who haven't
really lived it starts tomorrow and
dom pia full of hits
I think we were failures so we
lost but I said it's part of football is to
lose and win
we don't want it
that way right but first  they
ran to get it until the end, it could have
a first six to zero 7 to 0 they don't
stop running they didn't mess up they
didn't do any of that with her as men
dedicate themselves until the end
it's not because after this
defeat we took it, we feel
humiliated,
we feel ashamed, right because
we didn't want that, it's because we
have a family because we have a people
who support us,
no one needs to tell us that they
are seeing you, you are the shame of
Brazil, I'm not ashamed of  being
Brazilian and I'm not
ashamed to say that I was part of this
team that lost 71 I'm not ashamed,
right, it's the only thing I have to
say that I'm proud of
my parents.  comrades
lubna hands over the ring where I stopped a
feast here is because he today
the life of an athlete is moved by
challenges
some are imposed on us others are the
result of a decision of ours
to keep the light that illuminates our
career what the press more  I like not to
take
the partner
to barcelona the other but the challenge
was a childhood dream because playing to
conquer here in my time there was no
catalog 21 hours
full of challenges until today I remember one of the
first days of dressing room activism or
with titles such as Dutch master  key f
put on request because, among others,
in the expectation of playing in a club
like messi, barcelona is a nation that
represents capital to take one of playing
with an athlete here in life and I'm
sure I won't see another one
[Music]
fascinates me  1 it
was me the rate starts soares that made
history with which everything is framed
you can conquer had unforgettable moments
I live in a city that is more than a
city it is a homeland like barce  canvas is
a cause plus an athlete
in the case it takes challenges for the second
time in my life with i will bring my father father i
understand and respect your opinion
the measurement of the outlet there i hope you
can not consider so me and god i
was happy from the same school
i am  convinced that yes
[Music]
the barcelona champion we are including in the
heart but it needs new challenges
to follow the proposal of the country to try
new conquests and help the club to
reach the titles that I only rooted to
present a very used career plan
and I feel  ready for this
challenge he could fall from the wonderful
blaugrana crowd that's all I
learned from the great athletes with whom he
shared this year but yes in my heart
it's time to leave
the opinion of my home in the coming years I will
work to honor all the trust
deposited in my football
at the most with the support of all of you
fans who are committees that 2009
my friends of the professionals who
accompany and especially the m  my
family suffered a lot with the problems
that occurred in this period of my
career that today deserve peace is a
very difficult decision but it was taken with
maturity that accumulates number 25 years old
lady bresso paris office the
daughter god bless and protect love of
all boys  girls top go no and no kombi
cambate good imei good climbing or weak
good or i already knew there were a lot of ti
player or enem come to get worse
who gave direction
[Applause]
only the lion malls gleinol objective to go
and come back
is good didn't you see  and not in the street war and don't
look at neymar i only act on da all bass is
gas put goodbye and old splendor
lighter was adriana batman give a big
kiss thank you for the affection and say
something to you
i hope you believe what you
want  go in search of your dreams is
that you run after it's never just you know
you can get it's a big kiss
tires
in the grease bonus that neymar is useful or
harry tincknell gem for giving cold blood
point nor which ones he had and  is in funds
latina should sheikh hatim life
business one one news bill mitchell hurts a
lot and the beginning is pina
scheidt to them between raul and northeast
erwin guth
i train a lot so that everyone
throws faster so it's time for the
game pay attention  and if more agile than the opposing team
I think that each generation that passes
has to be the best that the other is so the
same thing said my father father said
if you be my son I passed
things you have to be better than  that
one thing my son and i will
pass on everything i asked him to
be better than me so i say
for today is that you dedicate yourself
villa desfered from tap wood nessie
tanks will have in my jewelry leaves
fruit final is a lot  rigid and not
understanding each other
so the team walked away in gaúcha is